thank you
[Music]
and welcome back ladies and gentlemen to
just kidding news where we are your
source for breaking news four weeks
later
here we go and with special guest hosts
Jason Cheney in the building
thank you thank you I'll tag me whenever
you need I will but if you tag me and
I'm refusing it's because I'm liking
what you're doing gotta get the Sriracha
well thank you for um letting me read
the article wow
all right okay ladies and gentlemen boys
and girls this one is uh really a a good
one cool
he's getting comfortable whoa I like it
because I read it already so I know what
it is
um yeah I'm a professional
um it's a Florida dad accused of
shooting
I like to tell them there's one dad and
then reveal the second then
all right everyone forget that oh
everyone
Ryan tactic I [ __ ] up yeah bring it up
real quick [ __ ] okay or we could do it
your
ways Florida Dad I'm the weatherman
um accused of shooting each other's
daughters in road rage incident
[Laughter]
[ __ ] live this news is breaking are
you [ __ ] kidding that's pretty crazy
accused of shooting each other's
daughters whoa so they're probably
driving side by side and they're having
a like that and they shoot up it's crazy
that is crazy got it for daughter though
right no they're not that accurate they
can't be right well maybe they're trying
to shoot each other in the Mist that's
fair trade this is the part where we're
gonna show them okay we're gonna show
them the uh the uh suspects because
sometimes it's important especially when
it's Florida people to show them what
they look like so these are what's wrong
with Florida they're Two Dads but really
it's just one dad without the beard and
one
this is what all Florida Dads look like
it's just different lengths in beards
that's [ __ ] good I apologize no you
don't have to apologize you're the host
right yeah
no apology but more information yep
um
two Florida men are each facing
attempted murder charges after they
alleged allegedly we learned that word
earlier allegedly shot at each other's
daughter during a road rage instead of
Saturday night so a lot of things happen
Saturday nights
the other article if you watch JK news
the other article yeah was also Saturday
the day before church exactly and I was
on the west coast and this is on the
East Coast exactly yeah so it's a
national problem exactly right now it's
as a national problem
William Joseph Haye hell
why'd you laugh yeah why'd you laugh
William Joseph Hill is the thing I was
I'm trying to spice it up a little bit
just say the word before you finish
reading it you have like three letters
you're like that's good enough
[Laughter]
okay Joseph William Joseph Hale or as
his mom called him Joseph William Hale
35.
I made it up okay I don't know if he has
a mom but uh and Frank Gillard Ellison
which is
43 so that's a guy also
we're both arrested after a cat and
mouse so you know you know what kind of
mouse is Tom and Jerry you know they
chase high speed chase on Highway One
I never heard of Highway One raise your
hand if you heard of Highway One Florida
in Florida I don't know exactly thank
you
okay Highway One in Nassau excuse myself
please no don't go please go ahead I
will want it in a Nassau County which
Nissa is what we all know in the
Caribbeans or Southern America there's a
Nassau yeah and this is the county in
America in Florida interesting that's
actually pretty cool yeah yeah I know
some stuff and uh the two men began
arguing with each other on the road
while hey I'm reading more smoothly I'm
actually understanding the story yeah me
too me too me too this is exciting she's
gotta do it see that's what people say
they say that if the more you practice
the more you're better at reps yeah
right explosion
the two men begin arguing with each
other on the road while driving
aggressively and break checking each
other oh yeah according to Jefferson
yeah so go ahead no oh no okay so go
ahead things got so intense and witness
told Nassau County Sheriff deputies that
he knew something bad was going to
happen so this is like a bystander he
was just you know on the freeway
probably I don't know if he was but
somebody told somebody it was a witness
so witness you know they saw something
yeah so he's probably on the freeway
yeah yeah probably on the freeway
somebody said something somebody told
somebody with a specific right yeah but
what are scenarios anybody else is
somebody yeah there's a couple back of a
pickup truck things are so intense
so tense you already read that one
that's I'm just trying to reiterate get
us back on track they were both speeding
and driving recklessly uh north of
Jacksonville they repeated the same
thing so I don't know why he's like it's
not me man the article that's when the
front passenger of the Nissan put her
hand out the window and flipped the
other vehicle off with her middle finger
so the one you know you know the middle
finger as Alice enrolled his window down
to shout at hail someone from the Dodge
Ram threw a plastic water bottle into
into his car no that's a nice nice shot
man yeah that's a really good shot
especially on the highway yeah I went
one we never heard about that exactly
wow exactly good aim the driver of
Nissan Elson then grabbed his six hour
45 caliber
automatic handgun sorry automatic
handgun yeah automatic handle so it's
probably stuff oh yeah very illegal I
don't even think they make that I think
that's a typo they can't just type
random [ __ ] like that automatic hair
dude you could do that like on a Glock
yeah I've heard of Glock once but I've
never heard a six hour no that's very
true that's crazy they're probably
really modded or something you might be
able to it's just I've never heard it
from a six sorry yeah in fact one shot
one shot why you say automatically fire
one shot
one shot at the truck now he knows this
is a good hose
because it could be the journalist just
wants to spice those just throwing in
random words yeah probably what they do
that
that's [ __ ] up dude we report the news
for real but some people they want fully
semi-automatic which doesn't even make
sense two different things that sounds
crazy to someone that doesn't know
people love the adjectives yeah okay
fully semi-partial for you so much it's
cool you caught that though yeah fire
one one uh one shot at the truck before
driving away uh at a high rate of speed
so just fast say fast you know
according to leaper do you know who
leapers I don't you know so why'd you
say the name the bulletin
the bullet into the right rear passenger
door oh no hell's Dodge Ram and struck
his uh five-year-old daughter in the
lane five years old oh my god oh damn
that will hurt my heart
don't worry don't make me angry it was
my
it was would it make you do this next
part after hell realized his daughter
been shot he sped up to the Nissan and
used his Glock nine millimeter which is
a smaller bullet
um because he probably got a bigger
penis
um semi-automatic handgun began firing
at Allison's car is it fully
semi-automatic no it's just this one is
semi-automatic the fact that he knew
that it's smaller bullet impressed the
fact that he knew that because it's
smaller but he must have a larger penis
amazing hosting right thank you this guy
knows guns that's what's up where you at
all day Steve this is guns
three of Hell's bullets struck Ellison's
car one hitting his 14 year old in the
back
she's the one that flipped off the the
guy huh
causing a collapsed lung oh oh my God
that's [ __ ] up oh because that's in an
emergency because you call only did she
die
we will continue
after the second child was shot hell and
Allison spotted an ncso patrol car which
police car
[Laughter]
they pulled over and argued face to face
with both kids hit that's so [ __ ] up
right they're [ __ ] dumb so crazy
immediately what are the odds of these
two people meeting and maybe they're
like it's not you shot my dog maybe
they're just like oh my God you look
like me without a beard and it's very
confusing so I understand their
situation they do look very
of two people like that meeting each
other and having an altercation yeah
yeah it's like they're the same [ __ ]
destructive individual same guy right
fire and rescue units took both girls uh
to a local hospital where they were
treated with non-life-threatening
gunshot wounds oh that's good okay thank
goodness yeah Jesus Christ dude with
your kid in the car hail then punched
the other father in the dick
are you freestyling now
a little bit I
think somebody started he's like I have
the power
there's a play-by-play of what punch
went where there's a left hook to the
dick
officer is taking the report so you
punched him where
sir in the dick all right well
there you go news article
Alice in hell was booked into Nassau
County Jail on charges of felony to
attempt murder officer concluded in each
of the arrests report their act was
immediately dangerous and demonstrated
uh depraved
which is like deprived I'm guessing
different my mind without regarding for
human life so which is uh both men are
out of bail so they're still they're
already out on Bill yeah they're having
a great time
no they should they should take both of
their abilities to own a firearm away
for like yeah 100 there's one guy does
the guy that shot second does he get a
self-defense thing no no your kid got
hit yeah and you don't think about first
aid but when you think about revenge
instead of first aid no would you all
just go to the hospital immediately yeah
would you take a picture of their
license plate or you don't I would try
to but like okay if you have like a a
lethal or potentially lethal situation
you need to address that yeah it's like
getting bit by a [ __ ] Cobra yeah and
then you're like
I dress the [ __ ] Cobra first you know
yeah where's that Cobra's daughter yeah
I don't know my revenge you're just
smashing eggs instead of taking the
betterment priorities you know
priorities so is that a tourniquet
situation if you get shot in the leg uh
yeah depending on how yeah you would
depending on how far up the leg
hopefully it was like knee down then
it's just because the closer it gets to
the artery here you can be you can be
you can bleed out in like under 120
seconds are you still training are you
still trained to do tourniquets do you
remember like in and do you practice
yeah it's pretty easy like you just go
to the highest point and you just crank
the [ __ ] as tight as you can and
you tie it and hopefully you have a
permanent marker and then you just write
the time and you also and you also raise
that limb yeah and you write that time
so when the paramedics arrive they know
how long the tourniquet's been on so if
you're like on the leg or something like
that and you tourniquet it it's still
better to like raise that above your
heart level in order to make sure the
bud slowly is processing that area
otherwise the gravity is going to [ __ ]
that blood flow up and is it is there a
way to do it wrong where you could make
it worse
make what worse the bleeding I was
watching this thing saying like if you
if you don't really know and you're just
trying you could potentially do an
incorrect tourniquet and just [ __ ] the
person over oh maybe I don't know but
you're trying to stop the bleeding so
whatever yeah I think the idea of
tourniquet is stop blood flow if like
you didn't need to stop left when you
stop blood flow you're also kind of
sacrificing something as well so I think
that's more quickness to wrong the flow
is like like when you have like an
emergency trauma situation uh the old
school of thought is like you arrive to
a situation like I see Nick unconscious
before it's like you try to check the
pulse or if you see his chest rising or
going down
blood flow can can kill a person much
faster than if he lacks oxygen so
actually the first thing you do is touch
everywhere to see if he's bleeding is
there is it wet anywhere and you address
all tourniquets first before you even
apply CPR that's how important it is
because you can bleed out like that yeah
that's actually really important
information productive if you try to do
CPR instead of addressing yeah so what's
dope is like when like at the in gun
communities when they have like these
self-defense classes and stuff like that
and and the people that use the Second
Amendment as the argument as like well
if there's a perpetrator and because
other people are armed I'm able to put
this person down the argument for those
guys is well if that's truly what you
believe in that the Second Amendment is
also a life-saving device
for as many guns that you have you
should have almost like five to ten
times the amount of tourniquets whoa
right because I get cheese so if you're
like like for example like one really
unfortunate event is the shooting in
Vegas at the country yeah if every
person that had a gun had five
tourniquets on them imagine how many
lives could have been saved if
the goal rather than if but but the fake
people they just want an excuse to go
Rambo where's The Gunshot come from I'll
blast them well the if you're gonna be
way more productive if you take care of
the casualties around you well what
about the video of Dan Bilzerian running
to his car to get his gun do you think
that was pretty cool
I didn't see that one but that's
counterproductive probably yeah he's
like oh someone's shooting I'm gonna go
get my gun tourniquet gun
oh thank you
[Music]
[Music]